Whoa, where am I?
Give me a sec.
Oh, there I am.
Peekaboo!
Oh yeah, I forgot.
This doesn't work with YouTube chat.
Let me fix that, guys.
Let me fix that.
Oh, wait.
I can make it work for YouTube.
Wait, I can't.
Wait, can I?
No, I can't.
Give me a sec.
Try around and do this.
Wait, maybe like Maybe like This Oh Oh, that's not it Not it
Alright, it's okay It's Sunday, it's also a Twitch stream I
don't need to be that professional Alright Look, it's a
Sunday Guys, that's usually my Break day Because I'm having
a vacation soon so now I'm here uh because I don't want you
guys to run out of Tokyo before I go I want you guys to
starve I'm so kind I'm trying to make sure you guys are
alive on my screen I'm just so benevolent exactly I'm so
humble so humble There you guys go.
See, there you go.
You're not.
I got you guys.
Oh, I have one already.
I didn't have to make a new one.
Goodbye.
There you go.
Suddenly they were for remembering bounties at the last
minute.
Good.
Lucky for us.
I don't have any bounties.
So today is a chill day.
Blade Star.
Thank you for a tier one sub.
Thank you.
uh what else what else i know i saw a few agent straw man
thank you for the five gifted subs thank you thank you uh
agent straw man thank you for tier one sub thank you thank
you frank thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you
jokie winning the most i'm so humble vtb award for the fifth
year in a row thank you to the uh uh but yeah thank you guys
for coming i don't know what to do i'm like super i'm chill
maxing right now well that's a lie i was working on I was
working on some projects and stuff.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I can't keep this a secret because I love, I'm a blabber
mouth and I love spoiling surprises and everything because
I, I love spoilers and I love like, I just, I, you know,
like I just, ah, it's so hard to keep things a secret, but,
um, we're getting new emotes.
We're getting new emotes.
I don't know when, but, um, and they're going to be drawn by
Sachi.
So I'm super excited.
Uh, I asked her, I could commission her for some new emotes
because you guys wanted more emotes and stuff.
And she's going to be drawing some new emotes for us.
Yeah, yeah, I'm super excited, guys.
I'm really looking forward to it.
I don't know when it'll be done, but we're definitely
getting a head pat.
Yeah, we're finally getting a head pat emote chat.
Yeah, I know.
I'm a blabbermouth.
It's so hard for me to keep a secret from you guys.
I just want to tell you guys everything, you know.
I just want to tell you guys everything, you know, I'm just
being like, here, take it.
Just eat it, like force feed you guys, get like, like, like
your like fog raw and then harvest your liver.
That's why I'm overfeeding you.
Yes, eat up, dragons.
That's right.
Wait, what?
Oh, boy.
food yeah um oh there is one game i sort of want to play
it's the horsey game because i was watching snuffy playing
it uh playing a while ago um i literally like i just wanted
because i saw it on scene for a while and it's like this
it's like this like min max horse breeding game it's not
umamusame by the way it's like it's like some fucking wild
complicated horse breeding game where you breed horses, but
they don't, they're not always horses.
They don't turn out to be horses sometimes.
They turn, they're like man-made abominations.
By the way, speak of man-made abominations.
Um, apparently today, um, scientists have discovered how to
copy and paste brain neurons, uh, of a fruit fly into a
computer, and they didn't teach to fly the, the data, be a
fly so um and apparently on a similar note they got a bunch
of brains brain cells neuron cells and they made it play
doom yes so with today's technology with today's science
they're able to recreate um a fruit fly's brain on like like
digitally we have a copy and paste like and like the fruit
fly like the fruit fly in the computer basically learned how
to be a fly without them programming anything uh so they
didn't teach you anything just copied and pasted a bunch of
neurons into the into a pc into not no not just a pc
obviously but like into like a computer like a data center
thing and then it literally just became a fly it did fly
things And then also, they made a bunch of human brain,
like, brain neurons, um, made from stem cells to play doom,
which is crazy to think about.
Yeah, they made it play doom.
Return the monkey now.
Return to E1M1.
Uh, Gordon, thank you for the 200 pitties.
Thank you.
I thought that was, yeah, now, yeah, now I can buy a plus
one brain cell.
Yeah.
I thought that was crazy and people were like we can
literally copy and paste like you copy and paste brain cells
now and I was like that's wild to think about like that's
how far technology has come the fact that we can copy and
paste brain cells like
fruit fly must consume fruit imagine that
find the article it was so interesting i was like holy shit
oh yeah and i watched a video of some guy teaching an
octopus to play piano like it lived his entire life just to
be a piano player uh yeah here's the here's here's the
article about the fruit fly yeah apparently there was the
yeah apparently there's an octopus like uh there's a
youtuber um i'm pretty sure he sounds Scandinavian or
German.
I know he's from a European country.
And he basically, he saved an octopus from a Korean market.
Was it Korean market?
He saved an octopus from an Asian market.
But a octopus can only live up to two years maximum in
captivity.
So it spent 70% of his lifespan learning to play He
literally, he got saved, and now he's a piano player.
G6 Barrett, thank you for the tier one sub, thank you, thank
you.
God, thank you for the gifted sub, thank you, thank you.
That was pretty.
Yeah, I thought that was fucking neat.
He's like, he got saved from being eaten, and now he's a
piano player.
Yeah, so it dropped into a virtual body.
Okay, where they took a real flies connectome, the wiring
diagram of its brain, and simulated it.
Dropped it into a virtual body.
It started walking, grooming, feeding, doing what flies do.
Nobody taught it to walk.
No training data.
No gradient descent towards fly-like behavior.
It just literally just became a fly.
It just became a fly.
in the virtual world and I was like if they could copy and
paste the fly it's they'll soon be able to copy and paste
the human I feel like I think that's crazy because then that
means we're getting closer and closer to actually copy and
pasting like a human mind in like the virtual world and I'm
like holy fuck like me studying all these man-made horrors
so they're no longer beyond my comprehension soon yeah sort
our yeah but it's not it's not us it's a virtual data of
like um it's a virtual diagrams like wiring diagram of our
brains so it's our virtual self so it's not even us and we
copy and paste like our own brain diagram into that virtual
we can i guess we could do like simulations and stuff being
like it's like that black mirror episode where it was like a
date i don't know if anyone remembers the dating episode in
the black mirror episode where uh we're like to simulate
like which is your best match they have they run they copy
like they run a bunch of simulations with like copies of
yourself within yeah within the simulation to see who you
best match with so like yeah we can basically do real life
sim soon uh well not soon soon i don't think like our gender
i don't know maybe technology is actually advancing faster
like then yeah so it's like we can run we can play real life
sims there's gonna be some ethical implications to it but
but like i feel like that's really it we can play real life
sims with ourselves um it might be like ethical problems uh
with that but
Oh yeah, just like Finn in Adventure Time, yeah I was like,
yeah, I thought that was super interesting I mean, we got
like human brain cells to play Doom though We're getting
there The fact that we're able to, like we got like one
eighth Not even one eighth like um We got like, we got like
a bunch of human brain cells to play Doom So like we're
getting there slowly
no ethics no problem all for science
the doom the new benchmark for sentience
i think that's yeah but it's pretty interesting what else
did i saw
uh let's see oh yeah i was thinking about whether or not to
play Pokapia because um in Pokapia uh also tomorrow's oh
yeah by right before I say it tomorrow's stream will be on
YouTube I was debating whether or not I put today's stream
on YouTube I literally could not figure out what to play
today I was so like I don't know I just don't know what to
play today there's not hasn't been like a lot of like um I
think the hardest part about like five like just finding
games I think it's just hard to find games to play okay I
did thought about playing this It showed up on Steam.
But it's pretty silly.
It's called Minhera Ream or whatever.
I thought about playing this game tomorrow.
It's some roguelike.
It's like a roguelike anime game where you fucking...
You got your trap with this crazy Minhera girl.
And it's like...
it's like some rogue like gambling game and she's trying to
and you gamble your blood away yeah it's like balantro but
with dice and anime girls yeah girl thank you for the
goodies thank you thank you horsey game maybe and you know
what i thought was funny there's one person my friends list
that who it is he can he guess who this person is no someone
got it right right away yeah it was mint
yeah mint wish list this game sorry that was from the from
my steam if you heard said no i don't know oh i don't have
it honestly didn't hear it
um but yeah i thought that was funny maybe i'll play
actually fuck it i'll play that game tomorrow um but um let
me like send this to my thumbnail maker most likely it'll be
like 5 p.m pst um sorry to the eu goons out there that is
not an eu friendly stream but i don't think i could wake up
early tomorrow.
I don't think I don't, I'm sorry.
I don't think I could wake up early tomorrow, guys.
I need a, I need a come back from my vacation.
And, yeah, and whipped, oh yeah, whipped.
I didn't even realize there was daylight savings too.
Um, I didn't even realize there was daylight savings coming
in as well because I was like, um, um, Because, like, I saw
a Dragoon that tweeted out, like, is it PST or PDT?
And I just wanted to be, like, it's 6 p.m.
It's my time.
Because I didn't know.
I didn't want to.
I didn't want to fuck with daylight savings right now.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's whatever my time it is.
It's Toki time.
Exactly.
uh is it today national women's day oh i thought it was so
fucking funny someone tweeted out that um i can't believe
women internet women's day is 23 hours long because of
daylight savings
international women's day is 23 hours long
actually what the good what a coincidence the the jokes
right in themselves the world is such a funny place i don't
i don't even need to write the jokes
the day could have been any other day but it has to be
daylight savings time day
by that.
History, thank you for the 500 bitties.
They can't believe time itself.
Can't believe time is sexist.
I knew it.
God damn.
No wonder they always say, the time of your month.
It's the time of the month.
Alright, let's see.
Uh...
Wait, what was I trying to find again?
Oh yeah, I was gonna message my thumbnail maker.
uh we'll need thumbnail of this uh tomorrow yeah we're gonna
play manhara what it was called manherarium that's why they
say father time arlo thank you for giving me a tier one sub
to princess thank you thank you
oh my god do you guys know like when i was looking at the um
Oh, I don't remember if I mentioned it on the Resident Evil
stream.
But, like, when I say you can make everybody Leon, you can
literally mod it so that everyone is Leon.
Including, like, Grace and Timu Wesker.
Like, you can actually make everyone as Leon.
I love the modding community.
It's just, oops, all Leon.
the mod there's no such thing as too much too much leon what
are you saying leon is god's gift to the world how do you
think they sold five million copies in less than a week
um oh yeah you can also make him iron man i'm looking at the
mods right now there's one where you can there's one where
you can make him arm oh wait what the fuck there was a tram
stamp i didn't even see that there's a tram stamp for leon i
saw one where you can make like uh it was oh yeah apparently
someone made a xenomorph for the for emily's twin sister i
forgot her name uh maddie was it maddie
it's a classy throwback yeah they did like a they have
someone made one where uh uh where where they can make they
made a xenomorph for Maddie I thought that was pretty cool
um oh yeah apparently I don't know that talk about it you
can we can do dual streaming now without having to separate
Timmy's and Yimmy's and I'm still debating if I want to do
dual streaming because I do like having everybody on one
stream.
I feel like if it was like something special, like a special
occasion, I will do dual streaming, but I do.
Yeah, they were like, we're not going to enforce it anymore.
And they were also like, oh, it's not really, we don't
really enforce it anyway.
And I was like, that's a fucking lie.
I've seen so many people.
warrant get warned or get like a suspension for it they're
like um you could have done it anyway we don't really
enforce it i'm like that's a lie that's a that's a trap but
now um now they're like yeah yeah we're not enforcing that
anymore they finally put a blank statement that like they're
vague on purpose so they can pick and choose um they can
like pick and choose who they want to like you know um
depending on like who they won't feel like who they feel
like they fuck with and stuff like that uh so that's why
like that's why i didn't want to i didn't like want to like
like that's why i i don't i didn't like the split thing
either too uh and it's so that's so vague a lot of the rules
are super vague because of that um uh and now they not now
but like i think a week ago they made a statement where
they're like oh yeah we're not enforcing it anymore we're
not gonna do that anymore so now you can like have one chat
up there you can like merge your chats together now yeah so
it's vague on purpose so they can like decide who they want
to like you know put their foot down on certain rules um
yeah very like be selective over it so you know makes sense
it's you know they can pick and choose type deal but i still
don't really want to do full-on dual streaming only because
i like the fact that twitch is more of my like chill gorilla
hours too where i can just do like i have no plan and i just
go live type deal and youtube is more uh youtube is more
like my um uh you know i do have a schedule set on place and
like i have a plan know exactly what I want to do and
everything but I like Twitch being more more relaxing and
chill be like I don't know I don't know we're here to we're
here to vibe we're just here to party it's Sunday it's a
lazy Sunday yeah YouTube is like my office hours and then
Twitch is like you see me shopping at like you see me
walking around at a grocery store and you're like do I talk
to her do I He's like, I've never seen her outside of
school.
You see your teacher at the grocery store.
Be like, oh my God, what's she doing here?
She exists out of school.
And then YouTube is my office hours.
Is that my dentist?
Like,
that's my twitch.
She doesn't sleep at the school.
She has a life outside of school instead of just...
teaching me like she is her own person here's my cough drops
I saw my doctor in a commercial that was weird my doctor's
famous but yeah I don't know I don't know about I don't know
how frequently I'll do dual streaming like I said most like
it it's a special stream where i should do you know if it's
a special stream uh then maybe but like i said i do like the
separation and i do like um i like having everybody in one
place type deal
so most like it's just if it's a special occasion i'll do
dual streaming but um yeah
oh yeah also that it's people on day two of poke when
pocopia came out like on day two and i see the amount of
someone recreated dead by daylight no there's still a vaude
channel i just i'm just very very very behind yeah look at
this someone actually remade like dead by daylight in
pocopia here i it's like it's what's a day three it's day
three and we already have dead by daylight oh yeah oh yeah
here this is this is what i mean i saw this tweet uh pocapea
is going to be one of those games where i think i'll make a
super nice habitat and then i go online and someone will
have built the entire roman empire in the two days the has
been up and then someone made this someone apparently made
this tweet this was like day two apocopoeia i saw this i was
like what the fuck this is me when i see people terraforming
and animal crossing like what the and i see my town and
there's like holes in the ground there's like holes in the
ground and like paw holes and I'm like we're doing great
guys our town is looking amazing like the game that just
that's a whole ass village
some people just got it I'm so jealous I'm so jealous of the
people that know how to tear up for him
like my dokey fruit infrastructure is just 80 paw I'm just
like, I'm just like, I don't need to fill it up.
They'll just live there, I guess.
Everyone congested.
Oh yeah, and then everyone's congested in my one area.
Like, look at them.
They made a suburbia.
They literally made suburbia with a fucking park.
My town.
I was like, you all live here in this one area.
Like, it's like some communal, like some cult, you know.
It's like, I put you, I bunch you up all in that one cell.
like a cult wait not even a cult like a I have to say
something really bad
something something that we in Canada bad time in Canadian
history
Tokyo A very bad time In Canadian history
See, this is why we're on Twitch What do Canadians do?
Oh no, there's a reason why Geneva Convention was was
created because of Canada there is a reason what didn't the
Canadians do they don't know they do not know the secret
dark history of Canada yeah they're like what did Canada do
oh you poor you poor Unfortunate soul
Sweet summer child
What did they do?
I thought they were nice Poor kid
Yeah Let's play it You know what I'm gonna play Wait what
was this there If I want to play the horsey game Let me
check Steve real quick.
bada, bada.
I want to look into, like, doing hand cam stuff soon,
soon-ish.
Because I was, like, looking at people opening.
I was watching this video of some guy opening packs of
cards.
The only reason I have them is I keep thinking, oh, when I
get permanent play, so I'll look into hand cam stuff,
because I want to show you guys, like, merch and stuff.
I was watching, like, I was, okay, to be fair, there were
two videos I was watching.
One.
I was watching a live stream of some woman like doing
scratch and win cards.
I don't have a problem.
Yes, I don't have.
It showed up in my, I was just scrolling through shorts.
And you know how like sometimes live streams pop up on your
shorts?
So I wasn't, I didn't do it.
I didn't do anything, but it just showed up.
just happened just happened to show me this lady doing like
scratch and win the lottery cards or
and i was like i was like oh that's interesting let's see if
she wins and then i didn't realize i was watching for 30
plus minutes like i
i was like oh no yeah yeah i was watching for 30 plus
minutes watching this woman you scratch and win lottery
tickets and because it was just so interesting she was doing
like tickets for like different parts of the world and then
she's like every time she hits like a subscription goal
she'll do like big ticket big ticket scratch and win tickets
so they'll still be like oh all right we hit the goal Let's
do the $20 one.
Let's see what we will get.
And I was like, oh, the $20.
Oh, oh, oh.
I now understand.
When people watch gotcha streamers, I understand now.
I understand, guys.
When you watch gotcha streamers do polls.
Because, like, you won't do it.
But you're, like, watching see if they're going to get it,
you know?
So I was, like, watching this lady doing a scratch and win
lottery tickets to be like, gonna get it is she gonna get
that big ticket big ticket money like all that gamble with
none of the risk next see they give a super chat thank you
thank you then you delegate the bond channel uploading to
somebody 100 thank you for the 100 biddies i think it was
200 biddies thank you thank you i did but then like i told
him not to do it yet and then i and then like i still
because i I was like, I have to do something first on it.
And then I keep forgetting to do the thing that I was
supposed to do on the channel.
I took you out here with the ADHD Coco Melon.
Thank you for the 150s thing.
So I was just like, not because I was just like, oh man,
it's such a cool setup to do.
But I won't.
Okay, maybe in the future.
But I won't, won't.
hand cam stream will not be scratch and win lottery tickets
it won't be
anyway sure it won it'll be like one dollars i'll spend ten
dollars on the one dollar ones i really hope it isn't it
will be the second hand cam stream actually hey awesome Um,
uh, that's how the addictions start.
Also, I was watching this other video.
Um, I was watching this other video.
It better not be.
Okay, okay.
I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I,
I'm entertained by the sloth.
is real life slap um um well oh yeah uh also the other video
i was watching when i was like i really want a new hand cam
stream soon was some guy who was like i will end this video
after uh there uh i bought a thousand pokemon card packs and
i'll end this video after i hit the highest valued pokemon
card and he literally hits it in the first pack i thought
that was so fucking funny And I was like, I want to open
gotcha boxes.
You know, like the blind boxes on stream.
I feel like it'd be fun.
What the fuck?
That's just more gambling.
Yeah, I'm spinning.
Oh, wait.
How do you guys know I'm spinning in my chair?
Well, I'm not spinning.
I'm just like going back and forth from my chair.
Do not start.
I love blind boxes, guys.
Like, no.
God, thank you for the spinnies.
Thank you.
How many bits for Scratchers to be in the first stream?
God, thank you for the super.
Thank you for the bitties.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm just moving back and forth on my chair right now.
Oh, yeah, that's why.
Yeah, I can see now.
I can see why you guys can tell I was moving around in my
chair.
I'm just like, I'm just like bouncing back and forth.
I told you, Sunday is my, Sunday's my chill day.
It's my day off.
but maybe after my vacation um after my vacation i'll look
into it i think my very first hand cam stream i i just want
to show you guys all the merch i have like all the the doki
merch stuff that you guys like all the fat like stuff you
sent me from the po box and then we could do like po box day
or something where i could just show you guys all the not
the letters unless you guys write in letters where i can
like read it out loud but if it's like personal i don't want
to like know because like i know some of you guys write like
personal stuff in there too so i don't want to like invade
your privacy you know um but i would love to like show stuff
from that you guys send me from the po box because um
because like sometimes like for the po boxes um i look
through everything um um but also like sometimes when i'm
super busy i just like take it i just like go over
everything like because like i because i always wanted like
just show you guys the peel box stuff i want to have like
like i want to like do a stream about it so um there are
some boxes that i just like look through but haven't like
taken in yet and i want but i've been saving that those
boxes for like a stream in the future i want to do a stream
about that
all right let me check what i'll What to play.
I know I said that before, but this time for real.
Even your PO box is gotcha coded.
Let's see.
Do people even still play Mega Bunk?
You know, that guy was like, I'm going to reveal.
I will reveal who I am.
Because he was like, I'm actually not an indie developer.
I've been in the scene for so long, and I will reveal soon
who I am.
And then he never revealed himself.
I was like, oh my God, who is he?
Who is this mystery man?
This mystery developer.
And then he never told us.
And then he disappeared.
Who could it be?
The biggest clickbait.
actually Jeff all alive wait who is he I'm not a nowhere who
is he it was Kojima I'm not a big the vague post king I
fucking hate those tweets by the way um
Danny Dev and YouTube oh my god I hate like all those like
tweets now where every everybody's just vague posting be
like There's a reason why they don't do that no more.
Like, I'm like, what's the fucking reason?
What?
I'm like, what do you mean?
And then they'll be like, there he is.
The vague post king.
And it's everywhere.
It's fucking everywhere.
They're like, oh, you don't, if you know why, if you know
why he's like this, you wouldn't, or if you know why this
person is like this, then you wouldn't support them.
why just tell us why don't fucking fuck this vape shit like
what's wrong vape boy i'm afraid you might say something if
yeah if you know you know who's
daddy dev and everyone's like daddy dev the indie king i'm
like who is he oh my god wait if you I get why.
Apparently, Danny Dev backwards is Mega Bon's developer.
Oh, he made Crab Game?
Oh, that was him?
I'm not a knower.
I don't watch Danny Dev.
I made Among Us, but it's 3D.
But Among Us is already 3D.
And why didn't you want to take it?
he's still an indie I thought oh I guess like maybe in his
previous job she like he wanted to like uh he just wanted to
give everyone he wanted to give everyone a chance to win
oh the category was debut game oh yeah that's not his debut
game crab game is his debut game yeah yeah oh
I can't believe it.
Now I'm a nowhere.
Oh my god.
Finally.
Now I can be the vague poster.
Yeah.
Now I can vague post chat.
It's finally my turn.
But no.
No, but I hate those tweets.
Because I always have to look at the.
i have to look in the comments the replies and then someone
would be like the vague uh at grok is this like what does he
mean by that or like it would be like does anyone know the
context and i have to click on that and then just see the
replies the goddamn engagement oh and also another thing i
hate right now on twitter are everyone posting out of like
um out of context clips of streamers or like like they'll
have like some fucked up random controversial shit in the
tweet and then you click on the clip and it has nothing to
do with what the tweet said they're like at like where they
spread misinformation it's so bad
i'll be like oh my god the streamer did what and then you
click on the clip and it's just like I love ice cream.
It's like this streamer committed a crime and then like
kicked orphans.
And then you click on the clip.
I love ice cream.
And then you see the replies.
And then people are like, I can't believe they would do such
a thing.
They're like, oh my God.
I can't believe they said that.
They would do such a thing.
And then you know they're just here to...
be angry.
They got rage baited, but they didn't even watch the clip.
Yeah.
They're like, did you really say that?
That's so fucked up.
And then someone replied to them, like, please watch the
clip.
I was like, I always knew they were a bad person.
They gotta pay for that Twitter blue, guys.
So Twitter people being Twitter
But um, but um, but um, oh guys watch look at this
Please don't unfollow me Please Please don't Please don't
leave guys Please don't
Too late
that I was looking at my bookmarks I waited for this day to
send this link I
it was in my Twitter bookmarks I waited for this moment to
show it to you guys there's a very important link it's
Minecraft it's Minecraft guys
Everyone's already a mid-maxing at Pokapia, which is crazy.
Well, yeah, today's the last day for the Watson skin, too,
by the way.
If you guys haven't, well, if you start now, I'm sorry to
say you won't be able to get it, but if you still, if you
just need one more day to grind, today will be the last day.
I got it.
Yeah.
I actually got it.
For real this time.
Oh yeah, I also want to say, I even I forgot about last
gen's start.
Wait, is this last gen starters?
Okay, wait.
Um.
Pokemon starters.
Oh, not last gen.
Which one?
Wait, which one is this?
Which one's the one?
Is Quaxly the last gen?
Oh, Quaxly is the last gen.
I will have to say i didn't even realize quaxly existed
until until twitter was like please do not turn out like
quaxly yeah that this yeah i even like i remember seeing the
last i mean i remember the duck i remember the duck and then
i don't i didn't remember i don't remember this second and
third evolution and then I looked them up because of the new
the new starter discourse they were like please don't please
don't let the next water starter turn out like quack sleep
um and and then I saw quackswell and I was like oh my oh
he's a dancer and I saw a quackable and I was like oh and I
saw him moving and I was like oh my god hey
Oh my eye You made them No it's Quaxly, Quaxwell And
Quackville He's shaking it That's a zesty duck I think what
people were like Uncomfortable was because like he's too
He's too much of a furry People were like What's the
difference between the duck And the bird and people were
like The bird was less furry The duck looks like, looks like
he wants to do things.
The duck just wants to dance.
Oh, yeah.
Um, um, wait, what was I going to say?
Fuck, never mind.
Never mind.
Oh, no.
I was like, oh, yeah.
I had something I was saying.
And then, oh, no, I forgot.
Oh, yeah.
I was, I've been back on Webtoons recently.
I was back on webtoons recently and I don't know for anyone
that doesn't read webtoons um they announced a new comic
series of Mickey Mouse and friends crossovered with Formula
One
did anyone see that there's a new comic series where
formerly Formula One um and Disney are Right now on a comic
series, with Mickey Mouse.
There's an actual comic series.
I was like, I was reading it.
I read the first, the first chapter.
It's crazy.
It's wild.
It's like Kingdom Hearts, but what if they're drivers?
What if it's a Formula One?
It's literally like Kingdom Hearts, but what if it's Formula
One instead of the heart?
The heart?
There.
The engine energy of a Formula One Grand Prix.
Why are you in this shot?
That's wild.
Let's see.
So I can grab another comic page.
I read like the first chapter.
Oh my god, it literally looks like Kingdom Hearts.
It actually looks like Kingdom Hearts.
the sonic pose right now in the wait this looks like a
parody when I look at look at the cover art look at the
cover art guys let me even pull it up for you guys
this looks like a kingdom hearts cover art slash sonic
racing to the top
oh what the fuck
wait look at this It's that little sweet, oh wait, look at
it, oh my god, he's, Mickey Mouse is so edgy here.
Look at this one.
Don't give up yet, huh?
We can help.
He's so tough.
It's literally Kingdom Hearts.
It goes hard.
Hold on.
He's so locked in, guys.
But if you check out Webtoons, you can read the Formula One
Disney comic right now.
It's for free.
This is why we don't have Kingdom Hearts 4.
This is like Kingdom Hearts at home.
It's free, though.
It's free on Webtoons.
I read the first chapter.
It's so fucking silly.
They basically got, they like, basically the first chapter
was that they're like, they got an Uber slash taxi.
They got an Uber to the Formula One racetracks, and they're
like, we're so excited.
And then the taxi driver slash Uber driver is also like a
fucking Formula One enthusiast, too.
And he got super excited.
And then Mickey and his friends invited him over as a plus
one to watch the Formula One races race with him, and
they're like, we need a driver.
We're going to be part of the Formula One, um, like
competition.
And we need a driver.
Why don't you join us?
And so they recruited their, they recruited their taxi
driver to be their Formula One race car driver.
So it's fucking wild.
Yeah, they recruited their Uber Eats guy.
but i only read the first chapter because i was like what
the fuck is this like i keep i kept i booted up webtoons and
i was just like what the fuck like all
right the duckberg f1 fan club led by mickey mouse is
invited to shadow a racing team to create behind the scenes
documentary But when the team suddenly collapses at the very
beginning of the season, Mickey Mouse, Donald Duck, and
friends step up to keep the project alive, feeling key rose
themselves and recommending June a talented taxi driver,
chasing his lifelong dream of winning Formula One, only to
discover his teammate is his sister Leah, his ultimate rival
who left him in the dust years before?
Will June, with the help of Mickey Mouse, be able to
overcome the old grudge make peace with his sister and
finally play as a team it'll be a long journey to be covered
at full speed on the grand pre tracks whoa spoilers i'm
reading the comic right now oh he's a nobody yeah it was
that's what i'm saying it's advertised on on webtoons and
every like they were like sticking it in my face when I
booted up the app.
And I was like, what the fuck is Mickey Mouse doing in
Formula One?
And I was like, I was
so confused.
They got me.
They hooked me in.
They engagement baited me.
He's a very talented taxi driver.
Yeah.
All right, let's play the horsey game.
For real.
Do I want to play the horsey game?
Hmm.
But yeah, let's play the horsey game.
See how I feel.
I don't really want to play any rank type.
I don't want to like read.
I don't want to use my brain.
That's really it.
I just don't want to use my brain.
I just want to exist.
Yeah, today's just a exist type of...
Oh, wait, I should have something better than horsey game.
Wait, actually, no.
This is too complicated for my brain right now.
Never mind, guys.
I looked at the trailer and I was like I don't know how to
fuck with that right now I'm too tired for this We will play
a horsey game Let me get it real quick There was something
else I was thinking about I should try it and I was just
like I'm too stupid right now What was it?
It was called insider trading Where you like It's like a
stock market roguelike Where you invest in stock but it's
like a rogue leg oh there is this game there is this other
game i won't play but like it's a demo they only have a they
have a play test right now and it's like fixing uh like old
electronics but i won't play that as a real game later that
sounds funny yeah but that's too much thinking it's the
stock market it's a little stock market it's too much work
I saw it like on my thing so I was just like huh looks
interesting
all right let me up where is it let me play the horsey game
then I just I just want to be ahead let's just make horseies
all right I don't use the bathroom while I install the game
So I'll be right back, guys.
Wait, let me install.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
All right, it's horsey time.
Babbabomb.
All right, horsey game.
No.
Oh my God, it's so loud.
Or maybe it's just, no, it's actually loud.
All right.
I don't know if this is okay.
But it was very loud for me
Alright It does not like It might not look very beautiful
But trust me it is a lot more complicated Than you expect
This game to be Alright let's see Oh thank you mine Alright
Let's see if it shows up though horsey game hello horsey
game oh no does it not do game capture is it that type of
game oh no it doesn't okay there's no game capture for this
so i have to do screen capture i hate that
there we go
Okay, it might not look very beautiful, but trust me, do not
judge a book by its cover.
Trust me.
Alright, help, I have the horse flu.
I'm afraid the treatment costs 62,375.
Go bet on horse races to make money.
Alright, so we're gonna...
game horsey game but but but but um all right welcome new
player all right who you guys think pick a horse to win do
you think is sir out algor algernon champion crunch time
dwarf satchel or buckle loosely i feel like Crunch time.
Yuma Musa makeup looks kind of cooked.
I'm gonna go with...
Yeah, crunch time looks strong.
He does.
I'm all in.
Let's go.
My bet?
I'm betting it off.
Oh, $20.
Okay.
Race.
Crunch time!
No!
Runtime!
My life savings!
No!
Why could he move?
We'll get him next time.
Place your...
You know what?
I bet shameful.
There's no way I can't lose.
There's no way.
Wild Oh, she didn't even see why.
No, she didn't follow.
No, the track is this way.
No.
The track was the other way.
What do you mean?
There are no words.
No, I couldn't even see her name was first.
Okay.
um bring a horse here if you want to race if you had a lasso
you could catch a horse i had bob sells horse at a fair
price okay all right so unfortunately we are not doing so
well right now with horses but maybe uh maybe we can we can
afford a lasso like oh oh no
have do i have oh no did i soft lock myself because i bet on
horses too much wait okay oh no oh we're homeless oh no okay
wait i can maybe this time this is it all right major domo
loco shaka when the falls fell and Dreb.
Okay.
Who do you guys think?
I'll let Chat pick this time.
Chaka when the falls fell?
I see more of that.
So how's the sound, by the way?
I hope it's not too loud.
I'm going all in.
I should be enough if he gets it.
Oh my God.
That's literally a dog.
No.
Chat.
How could you chat?
How could you do this?
to me chat how that was my entire life savings
chat my entire life savings looks like you could use some
cash oh okay that's all right hard labor all right i got 50
i could buy a rope or i could spend it on the horse track
i'm spending it on
all right taking care of business let's go we're gonna take
care of business you got this you got this come on go take
care of that power you got it's every choice the worst one
oh wait wait wait oh my god we're gonna be like was it like
new zealand where he wins oh my god please number two please
number two please like new zealand and the ice rinks where
they all fell down and then the guy won or there is the
australian it's okay i can watch him get second place it's
okay i win so yay did i no only first place are winners only
first place are winners.
It's like, if you're not first, you're a loser.
I still can't afford that.
Oh my god, it's $50.
It's okay.
That means I can keep racing.
Okay, we know this guy is bad.
We know he's bad.
Oh my god, there's stats and everything.
Okay, he's old.
Okay, power player.
He's young.
Okay, he's three.
Oh my god, he's angry.
royalty he's literally royalty guys there he goes there he
goes please please come on come on you're so close just keep
going just keep going don't let this mad name birdie wins oh
my god you're the earl you're royalty
oh my god That's not even a dog.
That's just a wild horse.
That's a deer.
They ran out of horses.
They're just bringing him.
What the fuck?
This guy has a...
This guy is inbred.
This guy...
That guy is literally inbred.
They're all wild horses.
which wild horse one or three okay which one two that's not
even a horse that's not even a horse oh my god oh my god
none of them can actually race will anyone even make it will
they all anyone even make it oh my god oh my god my first oh
my god my first first horse my first horse let's go let's go
you're doing so well just just one by one step by step the
deer is doing it go horse go you got this wait what happened
here that's his body someone detached himself slow and
steady wins the race You know what they say.
They, nothing will go wrong.
Deer beat a horse.
Yay!
I knew you could do it.
Only a deer can win a horse race.
All right, we have enough money now.
We can buy a lasso.
Oh, all right.
Where is it?
He said he got it for me.
All right, here we go.
We got it.
We gotta get a horse.
Gotta hook a horse here.
What horse do we get?
Let's get that white horse.
Boom.
Get in here.
Oh, I can only buy one lasso?
Alright.
We got a horse, guys.
Let's take it back home.
What's this?
Beep.
Alright, you live here now.
What?
Oh, I can... Where are you?
You're two.
I... What?
Where shall we name him?
Is that... No, he's two.
That is our gold ship right there.
That's gold ship right there.
I believe in this horse so much.
But how do I place your bets?
I want to place my own horse.
Oh, I have to bring my horse?
All right, get over here All right, you go Okay, okay You
get in here I have not enough money How much do I need?
Oh, $25 Oh, I'm poor All right, we know what to do when
you're poor All right, this guy probably okay doors four
balls smoky and kato okay all in all in and they're off it's
okay i can get fifty dollars for free every time i shovel
every time i'm broke the game will oh my god how do i always
pick the worst horse he just stopped racing he actually just
gave up he it's My $50.
It's fine.
It's okay.
I got $50.
Now, now I can send him over.
He was just done.
All right.
Goldship.
It's behind.
Your goldship is forward.
Goldship, please.
Oh, please.
No!
Goosey, thank you for the rate.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, they all lost.
There is no winner.
There cannot even...
None of the horses can win.
All our horses are bad.
Alright.
Alright, so...
There must be a way.
Is there anything around me?
Alright, so...
My horse sucks.
Is there anything around me?
I know I've seen it.
There's the circus.
Where's the... Oh my god.
I should have fucking grabbed a deer.
I should have... The deers do not disappoint.
I should have just grabbed a deer.
Where is it?
I saw it on Snuffy's stream.
I saw it on...
Where is it?
I saw it on her stream.
We don't take Loser horses Alright, Bob's Farm, Chills Ride
There it is While he's sleeping too Goodbye, gold Ship
Goodbye This ranch is only for Winners I got back a lasso
too That's great No!
Dad!
Goldships retired, guys.
That's a rabbit.
These horses are useless.
We're only here to breed winners!
There's the sumo ring.
He's glue shipped now.
There's a normal suburban house.
Might rain.
Where's the lab?
Over yonder acres.
I'll take care of your old horses for $100.
$100 runies?
Why is there...
You'll find out why.
I have no horses.
I need a lasso.
Oh, I pay him $100.
wait there's a there was a deer over here all right let's
grab that deer from what I learned only deers are winners
all right grab you you seem like the alpha deer wait what oh
shit whatever I'll take him horse oh he's hungry 14,000 oh
my god you're gonna you're gonna make me so much money he's
so like the more the more they weigh the more i get where's
the lab by the way there's a laboratory too i wish there was
a map i'm so confused what's this is this horses i say hola
to you amigo
There's no rules against Deers in a horse race All right,
there's the glue factory Oh, I have to upgrade my car Oh,
fuck that All right, let's go Yes All right, let's give him
food All right, eat Eat All right All right Grace.
Okay, that's fine.
I bimp the rest of my money.
Konichiwa.
Let's go, Konichiwa.
Come on.
Konichiwa.
You're doing it.
You're doing- Nah!
I would like some cash, please.
Okay.
Wait.
Give me my money.
Alright.
Now go.
race.
Go do it.
Oh, that's a winner right there.
That's my real horse.
Wait, I did it.
I didn't even get to race him.
Did he win?
Did he even win?
I didn't even get to race him.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Drag a horse on the track?
Alright.
I did.
How does he...
Run.
Oh my god.
That's a winner right there.
That's a winner.
Okay.
Yes.
Alright, here we go.
Race.
He can win.
Oh my god.
Come on, come on, real horse.
Come on, you're so, you're real to me.
Let's go, go, real horse, go.
Oh my God, he's doing it.
My very real horse, he's doing it.
I knew it.
My son, real horse.
Oh my God, Fy, you're a winner.
You're a fucking winner.
you deserve it go fucking sleep my winning horse go eat to
your hearts content oh my god forgot to grab my trophy is it
still there okay it is i used to have the fastest horse in
the west there you go show me any trophies you win is she
gonna die is that my wife is my wife gonna die Oh yeah, a
horse with atlers.
What's this?
Shovel.
What the fuck am I gonna do with a shovel?
I'll grab some hay with my real horse.
Let's grab another real horse.
They're all winners in my eyes.
Alright.
Get that horse there.
Peep, peep.
Don't worry.
I got you a special treat, my very real horse.
For being a winner, I bought you a wife.
That's right.
We're here to breed winners.
We're a job well done.
I'll test the other horse She's a winner I believe in here
Alright wife horse
Oh my god That's a winner right there Take you guys out
Alright that's the sun
Wait Oh my god you're all winners You're all winners You're
all going to make me so much money.
All right.
What should we name the son?
Guys, what should parents are real horse, wife horse?
What do we name the son horse?
Son horse.
There we go.
Let's go.
I'm real.
ready I'm ready to win it real horse come on real horse yes
oh my god he's doing it he's so real no no not katobala blah
blah boss you're almost there run like the win it's like the
horse you were meant to be look at him go come on yes go oh
my god my all right white horse let's go let's go oh my god
come on white force come on white force oh no not the white
no he was he was She was too top-heavy.
Wife dead.
Regret.
Alright, Sun Horse.
Come on.
You got this.
You have the genes of half a winner.
Oh my god.
Buckle loosely.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, wait.
No!
Come on!
Sun Horse, you can't do this.
this real horse cat lose two family members i guess he can i
guess he can it's okay he took after his bump it was just a
very bad dream he had a really good dream and a really
really bad dream oh that is 42 dollars that is all right On
women's day.
He never had a son.
And his wife ran away.
I'll just tell him that his wife cheated on him and took the
son with him.
He'll never know what happened.
I'll be like, I'm so sorry.
Your wife left you and cheated on you.
That's not even your real son.
old is he now okay he still has he still has one more one
more race in him when do i unlock the lab i have the
genetically maybe i just need a genetically code or upgrades
what is this what is racing stripes and suspension lift how
do i get the lab again
one more right oh lift that's my very much real horse just
because he's a freak doesn't make him any less of a horse
this okay all right oh shit wait this is actually really
convenient What was it before?
Was it like this before?
Or...
Oh my god, he's upside down.
That is an ugly ass horse.
Where the fuck is the lab?
How do I create my freaks of nature?
If I don't see no freak...
Get the upside down one.
Okay.
Or is it?
Where's the upside down?
I don't... I saw him, but I don't know where he went.
He just needs a wife.
He needs a wife that could understand him.
That he deserves.
He needs a wife that...
Knows, like, what he wants.
You know?
I'm trying to find the lab right now.
Okay, maybe they're good horses.
Grab a horse if you want to trade.
Sizzle, sazzle?
Wait, let's test that Sizzle, sazzle.
Alright, Sizzle, sazzle.
Show me what you got.
Okay.
I mean, Sizzle is sazzling.
That's for sure.
You know what?
Okay.
I ain't never selling Sizzle.
Oh, what?
But she's a winner.
Do you sell anybody?
Oh my god, it's just cosmetic.
You just showing me.
about his horse he's just bragging me about his horses when
the horse comes sizzling does anyone know where the lab is
guys I need a clone freaks of natures what the fuck is the
lab how am I supposed to clone anything lab is on the But
where?
Spencer's lab?
I see the circus.
Somewhere past the glue factory?
Okay.
We gotta find the laboratory.
It's at the very top.
I'm po- Oh, there we go!
CRISPR labs!
There he is.
That's where I needed to go.
Welcome to CRISPR lab.
The power is out.
Find a way to restore.
I need to find a way to restore the power.
There it is.
I follow the power line.
Where I get there?
I have to turn back.
Alright.
Oh my god, it's so far away.
Hope to God I don't need a horse for this.
Oh my god.
How do I get over there?
How do I restore the power?
Oh, it's all the way down here.
There must be a pathway.
I knew it.
Why do I have to do...
No, you don't understand.
You don't understand.
When you unlock the lab, the potential is limitless.
See.
The power plant has malfunction.
How am I going to get the turbine to spin?
I got, I needed a horse.
I, god damn it, didn't bring the horse with me.
There's no wild horses in the area.
I fucking knew it.
I was like, do I need to bring a horse?
I gotta capture a horse.
I have a, I do have like, oh, the other one was speed.
I'm so slow.
There's no wild horses in the area.
If there is, I just grab one.
be like, here, that's your new job.
Oh, my God, there you go.
I kidnapped a child.
Hello, child.
There's no child labor laws for horses.
Yoink.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
He's eeppy.
Come on.
you got this just keep running there you go oh my god he's
doing it he's doing it guys I'm doing it I'm making it run
yeah go horse go
no just keep doing it just you got this you got this just
keep running just keep running you're almost there somebody
has to exactly oh my god he's doing it guys he's doing it
look at him go wait cannot Oh my god, power is on.
Look at that, I did it.
He's slowly walking.
It's just that easy, chat.
It's just that easy.
His new home mission failed successfully.
All right.
oh my god where's his head what's wrong with this horse
what's wrong with that horse it's the opposite of cat dog
there you go the lights are on now electricity is needed for
genetic research oh yeah we got a research we got a research
our boy our winning my winning horse
what's wrong with his face what face all right before we
sleep he has to do one more racetrack all right you go
wait what why isn't he racing is he too old where is he
where's your entry
Where's your...
What can't you race?
Oh, he has to do the champion's race Because he won two
already?
Oh, you're too good, real horse.
I don't think he's good enough, though.
I don't know.
You know what?
It's your last race.
You go out like a real winner.
oh come on come on this is your last race you gotta make a
name for yourself you got this my real horse you got this
he's just a late he's a late bloomer oh my god oh my god no
no come on you're so close no no he's not a champion he's
not a champion horse.
It's just...
No!
His last race, and he fucking ends it by being a fucking
loser.
He's washed.
My goat is washed.
And on a loss.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Wait, he still has...
He's not old yet.
He's not retired.
He...
Oh, he's normal.
GMO?
What's wrong with my horse now?
What is GMO?
Okay, we're out by this.
Alright.
My genetically modified organism.
let's grab that horse he's upside down I don't think he's
dead is he dead oh my God he's dead he's dead all right
we'll grab actually we'll grab the horse that had no head
that's a dead the circle of life no no there's more horses
to my right so I need to grab the driving upgrade we'll grab
this I can't have oh my gosh you can't afford it okay we
need what was it was above me right yeah there's some horses
here some very uh suspicious horses oh we got a clone there
we go we gotta grab this horse
wait what there we go Horse and real horse.
Alright, then we clone you.
Alright, it's time to modify.
There are four letters in the horse genes.
G, a G, a, and C.
That's how DNA works.
Alright, let's grab.
Let's grab your DNA.
And then we'll grab your DNA.
Alright, real horse.
race your last race oh my god his he got wise he got so wise
all right let's extract that and then we'll give it to you
oh my god he has no head so he can't drink all right we'll
go double what happens if you had two of this you're going
to be extra ultra winning okay just the regular all right
and now we breathe you have no mouth and i must scream and
now we breathe you
go go make me babies all right you look like a winner
sleep oh no you're retired that what do I do with retired
horses you know what
since wait you're old too okay I know where I'm putting you
in all right what should we name this horse
all right one is a winner and one was breeding
all right all right you go over there
oh shit what the fuck did i just go to
goodbye your purpose has been served
sixteen dollars just because he doesn't have a head he
served his purpose in life Does it even?
No.
Is it even sentient?
Literally only a body.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, wait.
I didn't see.
I didn't see his race potential.
No head.
No glue.
Come on.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Your limbs don't work.
Oh.
No.
Oh no!
That hurt!
His limbs!
It's over before he's busting it!
He's just busting it!
It's okay, I know what to do.
Come on, I know you're hiding something.
I saw it on stream.
Am I?
No, he's too old.
Real horse doesn't have it no more.
It's okay.
I know what to do.
It's time.
We gotta find another winner.
We all, we know what to do.
We all get the wild in him.
Where's the wild horseies?
Gotta get a real horse.
There he is.
Come on.
There you go.
Meet your new wife.
Okay.
That's a fine horse.
We'll make a prodigy.
Make me a baby.
Why don't you have horns?
What happened?
Where's your horns?
Oh, wait.
What race is...
Wait, he's backwards.
What is he?
Put it in reserve.
Why is he backwards?
My S-Roll.
Okay, one leg.
Oh no.
Oh.
He's walking backwards.
No.
I don't know.
He inherited the backwards.
He got it from his dad.
It's okay.
What if two negatives equals a positive?
Okay, two negatives equals a positive.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait.
Sweet home, Alabama.
Here we go.
A champion is born.
Okay.
All right.
There we go.
We have the champion horse.
that apple it just works and then maybe okay I'm gonna all
right I know what to do wait we'll send we'll send sweet
home Alabama here we're gonna check him out first there you
go oh my god sweet home Alabama sweet home Alabama oh my god
I told you a negative with a negative negative will make a
positive chat it works it just works yes yes it's working
Successfully in game in game with horses Okay, nice All
right, okay, what we need to do Can I afford a car now?
No, I can't all right How the hell does it work?
Let it ride and you die to see his board All right What do
we need to do?
Okay, we gotta grab your DNA.
This is champion DNA right here.
And I'll give it to you.
And then...
Okay.
And then you drink that.
And then we'll grab more.
And then you drink more DNA.
Drink all the DNA.
And I'll feed you.
And I'll...
Oh
Maybe I can make him walk forward
What have you done?
Um
Oh And now feed it to you what happened Oh, he's Tanya now
And I'll feed Sweet Home Alabama Champion DNA
Can't be that bad Yeah, see, nothing bad happened He
devolved Alright, well I don't know what happened to that Oh
It's okay, everything is fine Wait, oh Okay, we have 733,
912, 601, 1,000, and all right, that guy's a big boy.
We take him to sumo wrestling.
How good is he at sumo?
It's okay, they don't need a head to run.
The natural instincts will take over.
Okay, 912.
Oh, my God, Nighthawk.
Okay, you can just walk backwards.
Oh, he faces forward now.
Oh, surely my guy is heavier, right?
He is not.
He is absolutely...
Oh, oh, unless...
Come on, or Ezra!
Ezra, no!
Yes!
Yes, Ezra!
I fixed him.
Oh, Nighthawk is leaving.
Wait, I could have went for Nighthawk.
Oh, they kicked him out.
That poor guy.
Wait, I'll go catch him.
I'll adopt him.
Give me that.
I'll go adopt that guy.
He's a loser.
His career.
You're adopting a loser?
Don't worry.
I'm going to give it a great home.
Oh, shit, Ron.
Don't worry.
Nighthawk.
I'll make sure to put you out of your misery.
Oh my god, I'm like in the negatives from that.
We can't just let those losers run out free in the wild,
guys.
Shouldn't have lost exactly.
What do you mean breeds that makes more losers, guys?
Think about that.
He's just gonna make more losers.
Can you raise?
It doesn't even call you Jack.
Is it alive?
It's just...
Yeah, it seems so dope.
Okay, what if...
We have two.
Okay, wait.
Wait, what if...
What can we do?
Okay.
come on boom
okay he moves he moves oh estero's retired oh good come on
move hello hello it's okay see dude don't don't all right
we're gonna take these guys somewhere later wait all right
so we home alabama and you too oh shit what the fuck is that
okay all right let's go let's take these guys out back.
I need to grab S-Row 2.
That's a zebra.
We're gonna...
We create it.
Look, because they're not sent... Technically, they're not
sentient.
If you think about it, this isn't cruel because they aren't
sentient in the end, guys.
Is it really cruel if they can't even think?
Guys, the is candy they feel no pain they literally feel no
pain they cannot play doom exactly can i extract DNA from an
apple oh my god I can't oh my god I can extract DNA from an
apple
I don't even remember why oh shit I don't even remember why
I blocked the term apple Why did I guys why did I block the
term apple Where did that happen?
All right, let me let me fix that Apple-y.
Okay.
I'm trying to remember where it is.
Blocked.
Blocked terms and...
Oh!
Okay, I fixed it.
It's because I had a...
I don't want... I had a phone sponsor, so I had to block
Apple.
Oh, yeah.
I have freed raccoon now.
I forgot about it.
That was so long ago.
It was so long ago.
Alright.
I have Apple DNA.
What am I going to do with Apple DNA?
Let's find out.
Okay.
You got to sleep.
Alright.
I'm going to test you out.
Oh.
I will make you a winner.
Don't worry.
You will be a winner, son.
Oh.
I'm going to feed you Apple DNA.
Let's go.
I'll just make Apple DNA.
It'll be fine.
Okay, we're going to grab DNA extract here.
and then oh shit no I didn't mean to create that all right
DNA again I mean for you to drink that okay and then I'll
just grab all the DNA and then I gotta make sure none of you
guys eat this And then...
Apple DNA.
Alright.
I shall make you drink this DNA.
Oh, it's just a... just a normal guy.
Nothing around with him.
Alright, just drink all this then.
I'll extract the apple again.
There's nothing around with him.
He's just a regular horse.
Whore snail.
Alright.
Drink this.
Oh, no.
Can you still walk?
Wait, can you still walk?
What's wrong with his legs?
What's wrong with his?
I'm giving him too many probes.
so what happened to his legs guys okay wait we'll bio hack
this I did there we go go sample all this DNA there
we go I don't know what it actually does I'm gonna put it
all on horse.
This is the jeans of the most optimal horse.
The most optimal horse.
Did you hear that?
It's the most optimal horse.
But what does it mean?
Don't worry.
It's the most optimal horse.
Drink up.
Okay.
He's now a cow.
There we go.
We've made it.
We've made the most optimal horse.
This is it.
Can you buy this upgrade?
I need this upgrade for a while.
Oh my god, I'm so much faster.
Holy shit.
Alright.
All in.
And also Sweet Home Alabama.
You can just watch.
Oh wait.
Wrong one.
Alright.
Wait, no, not you.
Alright, here we go.
All in.
Alright.
Sweethole Alabama, I don't even worry about you.
What happened to you?
Sweethole Alabama?
Oh, wait, no.
It's just because that horse is more off.
Oh, that's right.
That's right, dwarf satchel.
Go find me.
home alabama kept him pure i kept him pure you're useless to
me don't worry the most optimal horse
oh no he broke his legs oh oh no his legs are broken What
happened?
What happened to my optimization?
What happened?
I don't understand.
He broke his legs.
What happened?
I thought he was the most optimized.
How can I optimize?
Wait, that horse?
His legs are long.
That's a long-ass legs.
Get in here.
All right, all right.
We'll put more DNA.
And then we'll buy...
There's rabbits here.
We'll buy the rabbit DNA, too.
What the fuck?
Okay.
These horses, house, hippo, we'll grab you.
I'll grab all of you.
You're no longer useless to me.
I'm going to optimize your DNA.
Okay.
I need your DNA.
Drink up.
Optimize it.
Why don't you want to drink?
Don't worry.
I'm going to give you rabbit DNA.
And again.
Stone.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
And then.
And I'll feed all that DNA I got from the bunnies.
And I'll feed it to you.
And then.
I'll take this DNA.
And then I'll feed it to you.
All right.
There you go.
We're so optimized now.
All right.
And I'll grab this.
And then I'll grab this.
And then I'll grab.
Wait, I can put all of their DNAs together.
Oh my God.
like a little Frankenstein.
And I'll feed it to you.
Oh, it's just the same.
Alright, extract.
Dragoon eats perfect formants.
Enhancing drugs.
Alright.
And then, I'll take all of you.
I'm gonna go to the lab.
I brought so many DNAs.
And I Optimize.
That's so much DNA.
Oh my god, I'm analyzing.
I'm analyzing so hard.
And then, with this DNA card,
I go to the lab.
I put you in.
I...
That's not what I would have.
But, I put you in.
I put the disc in.
And I feed you.
That DNA.
You are now optimized.
Let me grab this real quick.
You are now...
Wait, copy?
Gino copy.
What's this?
What the fuck?
Oh, is that the DNA?
Oh my god, that's all the DNA, guys.
I'm the DNA car.
Look at all that DNA.
How do I get out of here?
How do I get out?
How do I leave?
How do I leave the DNA car?
I don't know.
to leave.
Now do I leave the DNA car?
I'm stuck in the shadow realm.
Oh.
I can't leave.
Oh,
maybe I have to go up.
Oh, okay.
What is this?
Drink it.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
This is an apple.
okay all right we optimized now now that we've optimized
we're gonna go to my house let's test him out
maybe he'll make better children
okay oh shit he's backwards I didn't even notice that I
forgot he's back wait maybe they'll put him back Maybe he's
going to face the right way.
He'll face the right way, guys.
Oh my god, wait, he's not useless.
Come on.
Okay, he might be a little useless.
But it's okay.
I'll create babies with you.
Okay, and I'll create babies with you.
You are optimized.
You, I don't know, but I just want to create babies.
Alright.
babies all right we're gonna take you to the race can you
buy another haybell we're running out of
all right let's go i'm putting a rabbit in the race house
hippo i won't rename you this is who you were
oh i have to watch him get grinded up
All right, that's fine.
All right.
One of you must be optimized.
Let's test each child out.
I'll grab your DNA.
Well, we can work with this.
I'll just grab his DNA, guys.
We can work with this.
All right.
This is the DNA pile.
The DNA pile.
You've always been a winner, Sweet Home Alabama.
You've always, you know what?
I trust you in being another, giving me another winner.
DNA pile.
Okay, we got, we'll test you.
We'll test you out on the tracks.
All right, DNA pile.
DNA pile.
He just takes two DNA pile.
Okay.
Let's put you.
Let's test you out.
If you win, I'll name you.
Only winners get names.
Oh.
Oh my God.
He's so optimized.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, that's backwards.
Backwards is not forward.
Come on.
You're so close to getting it.
You're so close.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, yes!
For being a winner, you shall now be named.
He did it.
He actually fucking did it.
He has earned himself a name.
What do we name him?
Alright.
Sweet Home Alabama.
You need a second.
You do need a second trophy.
You will see the name soon.
I just want to race Sweet Home Alabama.
Oh my god.
A fucking course.
When Sweet Home Alabama comes in.
We have fucking buckled loosely.
With his freakishly long legs.
I need a take, I need a kid.
Oh, no!
A fucking curse.
This is his name.
One by a nose.
He died for victory.
He got a heart attack for a win.
And we're gonna grab all that DNA.
Alright, and then...
With this.
Extract them all.
And then.
Like, can I put all of this in?
And I'll give it to Sweet Home Alabama.
He's gonna retire anyway.
So drink up all that DNA.
Alright.
Into the DNA pit.
More off.
optimization oh wait that's wrong sorry i got too used to
going there i got
all right this is the final dna the wrong pit sorry guys i
went to the wrong pit
oh this is exciting look at all these simulations Nice.
Oh my god.
That's winner.
That has to be winning winner fucking DNA right here.
I'll make like four copies.
Alright.
Here we go.
And then with that, I'll go to the glue factory.
I can't afford all these kids.
I can't there's too many children.
All right, and then with that,
with that sweet home, Alabama, it's time.
What the?
He has no eyes.
What happened?
What happened to his eyes?
What happened to him?
I didn't grab my thing.
What?
What did he do to him?
I don't know.
What is he?
He has no mouth.
What?
What is he?
Can you?
Oh, wait.
Holy shit.
He's fast though.
Let's make kids.
Oh my god.
we made more of these we made more of them triplets wait
they're pretty fast though wait these kids okay not this one
this one is special all right this one we're gonna optimize
his DNA this one this one is might not be ideal Neither is
this, though.
But sweet home, Alabama.
Okay.
All right, let's go.
It's all right.
One out of three.
I take those.
We take one out of three.
All right.
To the tracks we go.
The
mice.
He's so...
Look at him go.
He's a speed.
He's a boring champion.
He's fast.
Oh my god.
I finally did it.
Shit.
No way I spoke too soon.
I finally did it.
Come on.
I knew it.
You have the back.
No.
Not now.
Let Drem win.
No.
Five foot nine.
You can't.
do this to me oh my god oh yes yes oh my god it's so over i
knew it all right horse are you ready to earn your name it's
so over we're back it's holy his legs might be stumpy but
look at him go he has He has the spirit.
He doesn't need the long legs.
Oh my god.
My champions.
My fucking.
Alright, what do we name him?
He has earned a name.
I think eyes and a mouth.
Mouth is a debuff.
I made a family.
of winners and three for three you're
right my champion bloodline I know what I must do I gotta
grab buy a car I gotta buy a car and then with this car with
this car we are gonna grab all the dna and we're gonna add
the car dna in here too and then we have the champion dna
into the system and with that with that we optimize even
further going further than where science can take us And
then we sample the DNA
Cachow You have car DNA now And then with that We grab We'll
grab two more We grab two more
Alright Alright We'll make more.
And then...
Oh my, this is 30%.
We'll put that in the...
Alright.
And then with that, we go to bed.
We...
Oh, wait.
We gotta send...
Okay, we gotta send the...
The failed experiments here.
These guys are not it.
Goodbye.
Alright.
And then...
with that we go home we go home we sleep they oh wait they
don't need to eat wait only one person needs to eat oh my
god they're so well optimized we get them and him and then
we make more optimized kids oh no sweet i should have raised
sweet home alabama sweet home alabama Bama.
You were actually...
Okay, I gotta grab your DNA.
We gotta make sure we can recreate you.
We got...
I need to be able to reclone you.
You are actually our best horse.
I need to be able to remake you.
Recreate the ultimate life form.
And then, with that...
a feat of true engineering with that we head to bed and then
5 foot 9 sweet home Alabama and my car you guys deserve a
nice vacation all right you two deserve A nice, relaxing
day.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, that's a problem.
But that's okay.
It works.
Alright, I'm gonna DNA you.
Okay, you're fine.
I'll DNA, okay.
You're a winner.
I don't remember which one was the DNA.
DNA thing, but I'm a DNA one of you.
Don't worry, I have the lab.
Which one was it?
I don't remember which...
I think it was this.
Is he sentient?
Oh, no.
He's smart.
It can talk?
Okay, this is the...
Okay, this is Sweet Home Alip.
Alabama, I think I think I don't remember All right, we're
gonna have to figure this out together guys
We're gonna
Oh my god, it's actually dead.
Oh fuck I used that.
Oh no, I picked the wrong one Oh no, I changed dad.
Oh no, that wasn't so supposed to change him oh my god what
did I make that's a car I've lost track of the plot I've
lost track what did I make I've lost track of everything I
lost track oh my god that's a fucking tree oh that was from
the apple okay We're not gonna keep the apples.
We're gonna... That's just the tree.
That's just the tree.
I'm not gonna... I'm not gonna keep the tree, guys.
I'm not making...
It's just that we're gonna get the tree out.
I don't know what's happening anymore.
Let's track up the plot, guys.
them eat.
None of them require, okay, these guys require food.
Okay.
Oh, no, no.
Here I go.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Let's take him.
Let's take, grab the car.
Let's grab.
Oh, my God.
I'm so uncomfortable.
Okay.
Okay, don't roll the way, please.
This is your look at your mistakes.
So cute.
Go!
Use the wheels that you were made of.
I hate this.
I actually hate this.
I love it.
That's horrible.
It's actually horrible.
I think giving a sub to Ben, but holy shit, he's running.
Oh my god.
My win.
What a great race.
No, it's not your fault.
Oh my god, that guy was...
Okay, he's actually pretty fast.
It was just unfortunate that he was racing against horse.
Oh, I fucked over dad.
Oh, he broke his bag.
No, I'm so sorry.
Oh, I don't want to watch this.
I don't want to watch this.
I don't want to watch that.
Oh, my God.
Wait, he sold all the trophy?
She sold my trophy!
Oh, I got $300.
That's fine.
Name the wheel one.
Name a wheel one.
We went to walk.
Oh, yeah.
What's that quote?
Wait.
How much can I write?
How much can I write in here?
Oh, a lot.
Okay.
Okay, I have something.
I have something, guys.
Okay.
okay okay okay oh god it's so bad it's so bad okay all right
okay oh
okay oh my god oh my dad you can live in retirement here you
just you can just live in retirement what if we make you in
the car have a baby oh my god all right okay and then we'll
take we'll take you to the race
You go.
I don't remember which one was the car.
Oh my god.
Oh.
He's so optimized.
Oh my god.
They're think.
$500.
Let's go.
My $500.
All right.
It's DNA time.
It's time to optimize DNA.
It's time to optimize.
Get over here, everyone.
It exists to race.
It was created.
It was solely created.
I don't even know which one's the car one.
I know one is for trees.
I've lost track.
I have too many.
One of them is...
One of them is the car.
One of them is not the car.
I've actually lost track.
Wait, which one was it?
Oh shit Is this the Is this the newest one?
I'm holding it Is this That one?
Okay It's time Optimization
Alright And then we'll dump all of this in For pure
optimization
All in All in
all right what crimes against horse manatee and then we put
it all in pure optimization it's time
right here full optimization
all right I don't know which one I put an extra tree in
there too just for the little fun in it just to make it a
little more fun and then we sleep who needs to eat in my
family okay you need to eat and you need to eat all right
you can retire you you don't you don't do anything all right
i didn't know if you can run oh my god that is so much
optimization they were so all right here we go
come on you got this boy go earn your name you got this earn
your name you deserve it all right I'm so horrified that it
can talk and they're off oh i think his legs are too long
he's not optimized enough but you'll suit don't worry you'll
be optimized soon don't worry oh you're not a winner don't
worry i know what to do to make you a winner i i know what
to do to make you the winner that you deserve to be.
Oh shit, I skipped the champ race.
I got too preoccupied, but it's okay.
He's still young.
Which one was it?
Alright.
Okay, that one's not the champion DNA.
That's for sure.
That one's definitely not champions what are you what are
you all right i got an idea guys i have an idea we can
always improve we can always improve it we just gotta keep
optimizing
right we can always fix him we can always fix him he can't
be fixed okay and
then we go back go back in stick that floppy disk in no no i
went too fast
It's okay.
There's hope.
I went too fast.
I could do it again.
I think you can make this horse play, too.
I got too excited, guys.
I got too excited about science.
was I was looking forward to science okay and then and then
with that with the optimization put you back in put the
floppy this back in and then wow exciting and I created a
cat and then I take this in, I extract your DNA, and then,
with the extracted DNA, I go back.
I go back.
And I put more DNA.
And I sample the DNA.
I run the simulation.
And then with that,
And with that Just don't worry guys I've created the perfect
horse The perfect horse Right here And then with that I put
him in I copy the floppy disk here And I turn him in And
then have it.
My horse.
I was just away.
I was.
Okay.
And with that.
And then.
I sleep.
Oh, he's too hungry.
Alright.
I make them make babies.
And.
Oh, that's not going to do anything.
That's just DNA fodder.
That's just going to be for my DNA.
In a car and a dog.
He has a head.
Do you think he'll go forward?
This is your time to shine.
This is where you're going to earn your name.
Luna.
Oh my god.
You got this.
It's working.
And yeah,
I told you.
He's so optimized.
I knew it.
I knew you were optimized.
His name, what do we call him?
He has earned his name.
What do we call him?
Yeah, that should not work.
Yeah.
All right.
My car has retired.
Okay, what if, like, this is all legs and this is a car.
So with that, we created...
Okay, I did not expect that.
to be what we create i gotta sell this i gotta grind this
car up okay we got yeah and then we have horse and then okay
okay racing optimization okay we gotta keep this i'm put
this here as my reminder
optimization optimization and then you got you just gotta
stay here all right take you to the racetracks oh I please
stop rolling away please stop rolling away is it here we go
we gotta win a championship oh my god go oh my god this This
is it.
You'll finally earn a name.
No!
Oh, it's second.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Come on.
No!
Oh, thank God.
We got back up.
Always second place.
Never.
Always the prize made.
Never the prize.
Right before the fifth.
This life.
Never the pride.
Moo.
Yeah.
No, no, no.
He jumped too far.
He fumbles.
so hard I can always optimize him come on you got this you
just need a head start let's go it's just get the momentum
he just needs the momentum guys he just needs the momentum
he's almost there it's hitting speed come on no he's so
close no he's so close so close.
This horse should be retired.
I've seen this horse.
All my horses have died and he's still racing.
It's okay.
It's time.
It's time for optimization.
We will optimize where no one has optimized before.
Okay.
And then with that, with that we send these guys out to die
like I don't fuck with these guys I don't fuck with these
guys one is a fucking car okay he's almost a car how could
he and then with this we optimize and then we will
And then with this, this
is exciting.
It really is.
And then with this, we go in.
And then I'm ready.
I'm ready.
to optimize
We just got out of car guys guys guys guys we just Oh Let's
get a buyer car
Okay, and then what was that What was that
Put these two together And then with that we go put this
here and We optimize and then
Okay, and then with the optimization
We go back we go back back.
We go to the lab.
We put him back in here.
Where's my... Put this here.
I don't remember what this one was.
I've lost track of the plot, guys.
And we optimize.
Surely he can move, right?
okay let's let's let's go home and see what happens oh i
forgot about this guy i i forgot about him okay um oh i
forgot about this guy okay he's still very much alive
Oh my god,
I'm so uncomfortable.
Holy shit, okay.
I'm not so...
You think you'll come back the other way?
Where did he go?
holy shit i'm so uncomfortable i'll give you we'll need more
cars
that's a head right oh thank god i don't know what i'm doing
anymore i don't know what i'm doing anywhere okay this is
this is whatever this was whatever this i created so we're I
remember this will give We went too far I've lost the plot
I've lost the plot Oh that's Yeah okay okay that's him
That's okay I created Him again there was a Plot I've lost
Track on where we're at Anymore I don't No, I don't know
what happened to me.
Yeah, it's back.
The guy is back.
Okay.
I somehow brought him back.
Well, that's genetic sequencing.
Oh, fuck, it's that.
Okay, we're putting this in the pot.
Okay, and this is the headless man, right?
This is the headless man.
I'm putting all of this into the pot And then we'll catch a
rat Because I'm catching a random horse I'm adding a random
horse into the pot We have more genetic variants
No please You're coming with me I'm adding a random horse
Into the genet gene pool Gotta go back to the basics
and then with that I extract the DNA and then I put all of
this into the pool and then all right
why was I I so freaked out when he doesn't and he just
freaks out that that actually made me so uncomfortable but
stop thank you for the super chat i think about 100 videos
they can take you you're begging you for it to stop at the
top but dokey must continue
all right and then with that
We optimize.
What the fuck?
Does he even move?
What?
Okay.
Okay, clearly that's not it.
We're gonna turn him back into the car of then i don't know
i don't know anymore i don't now try reading with the
headless oh my god you're right you're so right i don't even
know if he's old i can't see his name i i'm pretty sure he's
retirement age right now i'm putting him in retirement my
first freak oh he's not he's not yet He still has some youth
in him.
I couldn't tell.
Okay.
My dad is old.
You get to go retire.
What happens here?
Oh.
That's no longer a horse.
That's...
Will I ever win the championship?
Oh.
How are you not old yet?
Holy shit, you live so long.
All right, keep going.
This is my oldest living.
He has a very...
Oh my god, Nimbabwe, why are you always here?
Get out of here.
Get out of this race.
Oh my god, my first championship, I knew you would win.
I don't know no no no I celebrated too early
okay I don't know what to do with these guys yes you're
freaking me out all right no I didn't even get chance to
race oh wait wait I can turn him into this guy and then
you're going to a race with me
Okay, it's fine.
I'll retire you and we all know what I'm gonna do with that
I don't know what to do with a car and also like I don't
think he can race
What if he fucks a car?
What if he fucks a horse?
Maybe they'll have oh, okay.
I mean that's normal Okay, okay, it's fine We're gonna try
one more time with you He just needs a head.
Oh my god.
There you go.
Oh, there you go.
He's doing it.
He just has to go to right.
What the fuck?
It's not even a horse.
That's an alley here.
The other horse tied up.
Shocked.
More like tied with fucking sheer fear.
They got a heart attack.
What they saw did it Alright I want to know if this actually
Race Why Are you afraid?
Why are you Surprised by Alligate?
Look at what you created I created Winners I know what
you're Talking about Oh he can't move I thought he couldn't
move Alright here we go You know that drill alright you're
my experimentation we're gonna optimize again guys we're
gonna optimize okay all of you this is your entire job and
then we're gonna add extra DNA we're gonna add we're gonna
add some extra DNA into the mix promote some more genetic
variety all right we're long past john we're long past
optimization we're optimizing chat
yeah wait we could trade a horse he trades right for a
hundred and it i'll buy you he has a cool ass tie it's a
horse yeah very optimized horse oh I now add rabbits for
genetic variety too okay get oh my god I already took all
the rabbits alright here we go pure optimization right here
alright
got my car okay we extract all that juicy DNA.
I know that's why it's extra sick.
He has a... Okay.
And then...
Oh yeah, which is which?
Wait, I...
Which one is which?
Guys, I've lost track of the plot.
I don't know which one I... Okay, they're all useless.
All of it is useless.
We put all of it into the pit.
We put it all into the pit.
And then...
Wait, I'll keep the baby.
Oh.
I no longer keep, I'll keep Well, you have to retire Oh my
god, it's driving Here, we're It's driving away The Kia was
like No
Okay Mother, please He's escaping
Don't run away from your destiny.
Pure optimization.
We're keeping you two.
All right.
There has to be a lot of variety now.
This is it.
I am creating the perfect horse.
One of you will win the chance.
championship.
If it is the last thing I do.
What the fuck?
Can you, can you walk?
Can you walk?
I can't, I can't tell.
Okay.
Thing is, alright, we gotta extract.
He has So this guy has legs, right?
I don't know if this works.
I don't know.
Okay, we'll turn you back from before.
And then, and then, and then we're gonna grab another horse
and then give him the other horse juice because we need
legs.
They have the wheels.
But we need legs, guys.
okay he was sleeping so it was uh it was ethic kidnapping
because he was sleeping and then
we do this
we grab this and then we feed you this and now wait what
Wait, where's your legs?
Room!
What am I making?
What am I creating?
Keep drinking.
I just need you to have legs.
When I keep drinking, a leg will appear.
Don't keep stop he's getting smaller i don't know how it's
getting more compact i just need legs to start appearing oh
my god he's so tiny now okay okay he has he i create a
centaur car all right all right i have now created the
centaur car and then put all their DNA here and I'll do a
DNA extract of all of this and then with all of this in I go
out and then and then after that send card we optimize yet
again I think it was this this one was the original scooter
that we created has he like okay yeah no he can retire now
He can finally retire.
No, unfortunately, I can't put the guy.
We must breed a champion.
I will not stop until they win the Grand Prix.
All right.
And then, voila, we let him retire.
I have some man-made horrors Oh yeah, I still have this guy
Oh yeah, I was about to grind this guy up Okay
Alright, we're gonna retire these two Can you walk?
Esmeals came up How about you?
How about you?
No, his wheels keep up.
Oh no.
They're too off the bus.
I have an idea.
Oh my god, they're not, are they?
Okay, there we go.
We can fix this.
And then...
This is all legs.
So then surely it'll be...
Oh my god.
Wait, I think...
Okay, we're gonna have to get rid of this guy.
Okay, we're gonna race...
Yeah, one more time.
Before he gets too old.
We have to...
We have to race him before he gets too old, guys.
Okay.
He just needs to go the right way.
No!
No, you just have to go the right way!
I did!
I did it!
I...
Yes!
I did it!
I actually did it!
Oh my god!
I created the most optimized horse!
Oh!
We actually did it, guys.
The perfect horse.
Oh my god.
I didn't even want my own.
I didn't deal to it like a horse.
We fucking did it.
It's over.
Everyone.
it's it's finally over
clone him and make all his heart I don't think I can I think
there can only be one I can't believe it was so easy yeah
yeah no one holy shit can't believe it worked He's so
uncomfortable.
We're like, oh, he's dead.
And then he started spasming.
Holy fuck.
I've never been so uncomfortable of a fuck yours in my life.
Yeah.
Pure physics at work.
We did it, everyone.
I can't believe.
You're right.
It's time.
We got, whoa.
Guys.
last horse on the road.
One last horse.
Oh, I can't clone, unfortunate.
I thought I could.
One last horse.
One last optimization.
I had to think he ran backwards on his attempt all
it took was a headless man to be the perfect horse it's just
that easy
it's just it really was that easy I
want to know can any of the kids I'm gonna go sleep.
I want to know at the end.
Can any of their kids race?
Oh, no.
Do any of them have heads?
This is the only one with a head.
Oh, that is so sad.
We're just gonna...
Alright, we're just gonna grab this horse.
Yeah, no, these guys...
I want to take them to a special factory.
Later.
Alright.
It's time.
Wait, which one was it?
Oh shit guys, which one was the was it this one?
I think it was this one
Can it even move?
What the fuck is that?
It's trying this
all right thank you everybody let's look at my champion
ranch thank you everyone for coming to today's stream i'll
see you i hope you guys enjoyed my attempt at breeding
horses
Zuki, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
We made a family of champions today.
Wait.
Wait, my little pen of man-made horrors.
Of optimization.
Perfect, like you can tell.
We first, we started with real horse.
We progressed more and more.
Anyway.
The next.
Tomorrow's stream will be on YouTube, guys.
We're going to play the Mahara.
Rogue-like dice game.
So I'll see you guys.
It'll be at 5 p.m.
PSD tomorrow.
I don't know.
Like, it's my time.
My 5 p.m.
PSD.
I don't know what it'll be with daylight savings time.
So good luck, everyone.
I'll make a waiting room for it whenever I get the
thumbnail.
Snake, thank you for the 100 biddies, thank you, thank you I
hope you guys all enjoyed today's stream If you're new here,
I usually stream on YouTube But today, because I'm going to
be on vacation soon, so there's no schedule I didn't know
what to do today, so I went on Twitch So if you guys want to
check out my main channel, please check me on YouTube
Because that's where I usually do My main streams That's
usually where I do my streams at uh here is just more so of
like uh sporadic like non-scheduled stuff um we want some
more maybe other means i do have merch i have some merch
going on my dokey merch for the anniversary stuff uh we
extended a pre-order for the anniversary stuff for another
week so grab it before it's too late um other than that i
also have uh the watson apex plush which is today it's the
last day to uh pre-order the watson uh dokey apex plush um
and yeah then there's like my gamer subs code, my Fortnite
code, and my EA code are all dokey bear to get like a
percentage off of your, well not for Fortnite, but you know,
I can use that code to support me as well.
Hey guys, I guess I want to know whenever I stream on
Twitch, please feel free to follow me on Twitter.
That's whenever I tweet out that I'm streaming.
I'm going to keep up to date with stuff, also like behind
the scenes stuff.
Anyway, Sig, let's do a little tour, tour of the champions,
lost track on who was my next champion.
5'9".
Sweet home, Alabama.
Yeah!
They were so preoccupied with whether they should or not
they should.
They didn't stop the thionk if they could.
And then, Dad, he wasn't a winner, but he deserves to...
He deserves to be here.
It was very unfortunate where we named one of the horse,
Dad, and then he broke his back and it was it was not great
it was not he deserves this retirement home after what i did
to him after what i fed him all right it was bad it was very
bad back in here hey guys i'm gonna head off now everybody i
don't know if i'm gonna raid or not i'll check who's live
i'll see you guys next time everyone bye guys bye